i'm tammy bruce in for laura ingram and
this is a special edition of the ingram
angle a week in an hour from kabul to
covid and the worst in media we have a
big show for you tonight newt gingrich
joins us in a moment
but first this week will go down as one
of the most shocking displays of
government ineptitude in our nation's
history it's a disgrace that the biden
administration's incompetence and
ineptitude has left thousands of
americans stranded in afghanistan at the
mercy of the murderous taliban it's
beyond infuriating that biden and
gensake began the week on vacation as
the taliban took over the country we
didn't even hear from joe until monday
and at that point he was too scared to
take questions biden's abc interview
only raised more questions about his and
his team's decision-making skills in
fact it wasn't until late this morning
that the president's team apparently
realized that maybe he shouldn't head to
his delaware beach house today he'll
reportedly go tomorrow instead who wants
to stay in the white house during a
crisis anyway after hearing his disaster
of a news conference today we can
confidently conclude that the biden
white house and cabinet are simply
members of a gang that can't shoot or
talk straight they are a basket case
teeming with contradictions and
incompetence after a week of mixed
messages and fumbles biden's team still
isn't even on the same page
what interest do we have in afghanistan
at this point with al qaeda gone we know
that
al-qaeda is a presence as well as isis
in afghanistan
well now it's now uh clear that biden is
being kept either in the dark by his
team he's
completely lost touch with reality
america's partners around the world
criticized not the withdrawal but the
conduct of that withdrawal and maybe may
then question america's credibility on
the world stage i have seen no question
of our credibility from our allies
around the world the fact of the matter
is i have not seen that matter of fact
the exact opposite i've gotten
the exact opposite thing is we're acting
with dispatch we're acting committing to
what we said we would do
well what are they telling him now
someone should at least tell our allies
as the wall street journal editorial
board notes the chaotic afghan
withdrawal has shocked and angered u.s
allies and yesterday the uk parliament
held biden in contempt for his
disastrous withdrawal so much for
rebuilding nato another three years of
biden and we're going to be lucky if we
have a single ally left now joining me
now is a man you know is newt gingrich
former house speaker fox news
contributor mr speaker you've been in
government a long time uh you know the
world you've experienced many things
many of us have
i i really it is a remarkable there's so
many layers to this it is shocking it is
disturbing it's dangerous it's
frightening uh what are your thoughts
about what has unfolded in this past
week
well i think first of all you need to
see afghanistan
as sort of a warning sign not just focus
on afghanistan
but we're drifting into what von neumann
called a crisis of crises
across our entire system
things don't work
uh and what you just saw let's focus
narrowly on the pentagon and the
intelligence community you have in the
secretary of defense and the chairman's
joint chiefs two people who are focused
on creating a woke military
well we just learned that the greatest
21st century woke military can't defeat
a seventh century group of warriors who
are willing to die for their cause now
that should sober us and it should make
us think about china
russia and iran and other countries who
are watching this
whole process i mean by neither has been
kept deliberately ignorant
or has such deep cognitive difficulties
he just doesn't get it
but we have reports for example the 23
members of the embassy
wrote a letter of dissent which is by
the way in state department terms a very
big deal i mean you're putting your
career on the line to sign a letter like
that they sent it to the secretary of
state we don't know if the secretary of
state lincoln took it to biden or not we
don't know if biden understood it or not
but that letter right by people who are
in kabul said this is going to be a
disaster
uh the president's press conference
today he just kept now i started to say
he's kept lying but the truth is i don't
know if he knows what the facts are so
it's not it's not fair
to challenge somebody who maybe uh has
significant cognitive problems right
with lying if in fact he just doesn't
get it he doesn't understand what's
going on around him mr speaker he
doesn't understand what you and i see on
television yeah let's uh there's another
uh comment he made let's up let's play
this next note here about the cables
that have been uh
going around trying to alert them to
what's been happening in couple
can you say why after that cable was
issued the u.s didn't do more to get
americans all kinds of cables all kinds
of advice if you notice
that range from
this group saying that they didn't say
it fall when it would fall when it did
fall
but saying that it would fall to others
saying it wouldn't happen for a long
time and they'd be able to sustain
themselves through the end of the year
so what's strange even there with with
what you noted it appears as though he
might be slightly aware of it but then
someone has told him that it really
doesn't matter because they always get a
lot of cables it's as though mr speaker
we don't know
who the president is we don't know who
the center of gravity is or maybe there
isn't one sir maybe it is just group
think and and gangs and no one's talking
to anybody else
i don't i don't think you have an
administration right now first of all it
was secretary blinken's job
to make sure that the president
understood how big a deal 23
professionals risking their career
to sign a letter like that a descending
cable in the state department is a big
deal it's not it happens very seldom so
either blinking didn't do his job or
you know biden just didn't get it i mean
i can imagine i'm sitting there and
thinking why is blinking telling me all
this weird stuff i've already made my
mind up i don't need to learn anything
you have the same thing happening though
with millie and with austin how could
they possibly as professionals
allow bagram to be lost exactly and keep
the embassy sir they can't possibly
protect the embassy without bankruptcy
you know just even strategically for the
region in addition to the prison that
was there that had isis and al qaeda and
taliban jihadists was emptied it it
seems sir and as you look at the ground
here it's as though every decision that
shouldn't have been made was made and
these are people with experience why has
this happened it is not just a bunch of
mistakes and when we think about who's
in charge we hear about people should
resign about impeachment about a whole
host of other things what do you think
should happen what should the american
people look for and what should we
demand
first of all we should remember ronald
reagan's
observation that it wasn't what liberals
didn't know that scared him it was what
they knew that wasn't true
and so what you have is groupthink you
have austin the secretary of defense you
have millie the chairman of the joint
chiefs you have the president united
states you have the secretary of state
and apparently none of the four of them
have a clue about the real world
now if that doesn't scare you then
listen to the chinese communists talking
about taiwan and that taiwan had better
realize that joe biden can't possibly
protect him or listen to the europeans i
mean
today either lied to the country or is
so totally uninformed that it's scary
but our nato allies are enraged
uh for him to say oh nobody's really
angry at us
you have to wonder i mean how what is he
processing you see this is going to
allow him to think that he could just be
that directly dishonest with everybody
in the world yes sir i can't thank you
enough for your insight even south korea
is saying we'd like you to move things
along faster getting out of our country
this is a disaster of monumental
proportion sir thank you very much for
joining us tonight appreciate your
insight hey sean hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to fox news youtube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else